is it on yeah perfect
ah thank you so much for coming to these
back to back sessions and and um
i'm hoping that you can you can still
stay awake and
and kind of take in this content even
though you didn't have a break in
between but
um we're going to talk about
advanced.net debugging my name is tess i
work as a developer at microsoft
i used to work
um as a support engineer in the asp.net
team a long long time ago where i would
debug
all sorts of issues for
developers like us right now i'm more
debugging for myself and debugging for
some of the product teams at microsoft
but
um
i'm still using the same techniques that
i used to use back then
part of what i've done also in my role
was
to improve the
the work or the debuggers that
are included in visual studio etc but
we're going to talk about not some well
some parts of it is going to be visual
studio but most of it is not going to be
visual studio
in fact when i was talking to dan north
earlier yesterday i was he was asking me
what what is it about this that makes it
advanced.net debugging
compared to just you know normal.net
debugging
well
in my book it's because we're working on
things that are very difficult to
troubleshoot with the tools that we
normally use to troubleshoot
net issues so things like memory leaks
performance problems crashes
all of these things so
things that you can't have 5d by you
can't step by step
go through and figure out why you have a
memory leak
things that happen randomly
so maybe they'll happen today but then
it will take five days for it to happen
again or things that happen on
linux or mac and you're developing on
windows so
you don't have the same tool set
available on on the other machine where
it's actually happening where
on the user's machine
and or maybe it happens in the cloud so
um
also there you might you may not have
visual studio or these tools available
so we'll talk about all of that and
we'll also sprinkle in some dot net
internals into the mix
we're going to start this is going to be
a very demo heavy
session um
but don't feel like you have to write
down any of the commands or anything
i'll give you links in the end to
kind of go through and
and see all the commands and figure
things out
um
[Music]
what i what i do want to convey is more
sort of like how the tools that we can
use to troubleshoot these things and
generally how to think about
troubleshooting these things so with
high memory usage
you only kind of have to ask yourself
two questions
what's using up the memory so what are
we using the memory for and why the heck
is it not going away
and that's what we're going to look at
right now so
for this first example i'm going to use
um
a very simple.net
application
and i'm going to run it on on linux just
to show that the tools i'm using are
also very much working on linux but you
can use the same tools on a windows
machine as well
so
this application is
this a single loop that goes through and
creates
10 000 product items sorry this
um
puts them in a list so it's not
necessarily leaking memory
because you can't really leak
net memory in the same sense that you
can do in a non-managed
language you can't sort of like new
something and then forget
about the pointer to that the garbage
collector will always keep attract and
keep track of everything so but in this
case we're we're used to using it up and
maybe we don't realize that we're using
all that much
so
let's have a look at how this looks
so i'm going to run.net run
and let's see if i can increase the size
a little bit here maybe like that
um and this is just like i said gonna
sit in a loop and and use up some memory
the first tool i'm gonna use is a tool
that you can install with net installs
that's called
net counters
and
the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to run a command on.net
counters called ps
so ps lists
all the processes and we see that our
memory leak
item here is
1729 so we can then go ahead and run.net
counter to monitor this
say monitor.p 1729
and what this will do is it will do the
equivalent of if you've ever worked with
performance counters
or anything like that it really sit and
listen and spit out a few performance
counters and if you can't really see in
the back
um some of the things that it spits out
is um you know how much garbage
collector heap we have so how much.net
memory we use
how many garbage collections
how many assemblies a couple of these
things so that when we watch these
and and i go in here on the other side
and i say leak some more
we can notice that for example
this value
which is like the gc committed bytes
um up here went from 201 to 402 so that
went from 200 megs to 400 megs and if i
were to do this one more time
it would increase
by approximately the same size so these
are all these product items that i
created that's now leaking in here
this is a tool that we can use is to
kind of like
check check out what the
what the situation is are we leaking.net
memory if we weren't seeing these kind
of increases
in in the net memory we would be looking
at so what else could we be leaking and
something else we could be leaking for
example is if we use a com component or
something
like a c plus component that allocates
its own memory or we could be leaking
assemblies we could have some kind of
construct that would continuously load
up dynamic assemblies for example like a
regular expression or
an xml serializer or something
but we have this
um
and oh
sorry i was gonna exit out of this one
but let's go ahead and run that one more
time
and
we'll do it three times he has to have
the same kind of situation so the next
tool i'm going to use is a tool
called.net
gc
dump so dotnet gc done is also a tool
that you can install with net install
and it runs on windows it runs on linux
and what it will do is it will take a
snapshot of your.net memory
so we can equally here do.net gc dump
collect
and let's see if i remember what what it
was 1729
uh well i'll better do like
ps and to see uh oh no so we changed the
way you started a new process so 1949
and so
dotnet gc dump collect dash p
so this will then generate a snapshot
with the extension gc dump so literally
this is just
enumerating in the heap figuring out
like how many of each object you have
and
and creating like a statistic list of
them and the roots
so
with this
what we can do now is we can open up
visual studio
and we can load this up
so now i'm running visual studio on my
windows machine but it doesn't matter
even though i got the gc done from
from a linux machine
so
at least open this up
and i apologize i can't zoom in on this
um but what we have in here is we have a
list of all the types of.net objects we
have and we can sort them by
count
or by size or by inclusive size
so if we sort them by size
that means that we're going to look at
what is using up the most amount of the
memory
and one thing you need to know about net
for to understand sort of like the
difference between size and inclusive
size is that
the size would only include the actual
data that's in the product but a product
in this case is
essentially just
a list of
pointers to
two different
objects so inclusive size is the size
including
any real data in there
so we look at inclusive size so that
makes sense that makes a difference for
example here for the list of products
where the list of products only displays
um
in a list of products it's only 525
bytes total but
it contains a lot of product so
inclusive size would be like that but it
doesn't really matter we look at
either one of them and we might even
look at the count we might say okay so
couldn't really find anything with the
size what not the size will usually show
a lot of strings and
other like character arrays and things
like that that are a little bit
nondescript but we can also look at the
count because maybe we'll realize that
forty thousand
um
forty thousand products seems like a
little bit excess excessive for this
process i wasn't expecting to do to use
that much
so then i would go in and i would click
on this product and and what this does
it will go through and say who is
holding on to this memory and in this
case we can see that
down here it says
that 39
999 of them
are held on to by this array so the
reason why they stick around is because
they are
rooted in this array
um
this array of products and then from
there i can troubleshoot a little bit i
can't troubleshoot much more here i
can't see for example
any properties of the products or
anything because i only have the
statistics and the roots of them
but
this
a lot of times get us as far as we need
also one thing i want to mention about
this is i used the tool gc dump now but
if you are in fact f5 debugging and you
want to do this thing where you want to
look at what what type of objects you
have in your
in your process you can also go in and
create a snapshot in diagnostic tools in
in visual studio and that will generate
the exact same thing
you can also create multiple snapshots
compare them to see
if a certain item has
has gotten like if you've leaked or if
you've used more of a certain type of
item or not
but this is the first
the first tool that that could be useful
um
next i'm gonna use another tool
that's called gc dump so what dc dump
does
is it creates a memory dump of the
process so this doesn't only create the
statistics but it creates a memory dump
of all the memory that the process uses
including
uh in this case
g and netdump only takes the managed
memory it doesn't
understand much about
native
memory but we we will have things like
we can actually go in and look at the
details about
what some of these things are so
i'm going to exit out
of this one
i think
[Music]
for some reason i've had an issue lately
with
um
windows terminal where it's not really
cooperating on
after i clicked control c so we'll go
so we can now we created the
the memory dump um which is like this
core
dump on linux
we can now go in and run dotnet dump
again
um
see.netdump
but in this case we're gonna do analyze
so it's both a collector
and a tool to actually debug memory
dumps with
so analyze and we're going to analyze
this memory dump and this puts us in a
place where we can run a number of
commands and then commands we can run
you can see by help so
a couple of the commands that we can run
are for example
um
[Music]
looking at the clr stack so looking at
the net stacks of the threads or
looking at
the memory used and things like that so
if i go in and run one of the commands
which is e version
i will see that this is a process that
was running
dot net 6.0
it was running in workstation mode so
workstation mode is one of the modes
that you run
the garbage collector in and we have
workstation and server
where workstation mode is meant for
things like console apps and things like
that that don't don't have a lot of
concurrent requests coming in where
server mode is something you would run
in
on a web server where you have a lot of
concurrent requests
and you have one garbage collector
thread per heap or per per processor
per processor or per
um
[Music]
per core if you will
and they behave a little bit differently
so the workstation is a bit more
blocking but it doesn't block the ui
thread the
the server mode
tries to
coordinate
then in my case eight different gc
threads we'll see that in a bit uh i can
run
e heap gc
all of these commands come from a tool
called sos which is
short for son of strike where this was
something that me and my team worked on
a long long time ago
on making.net more debuggable
and
son of strike is
an extension of another tool that is
called strike for strike the lightning
in the very old days
and when i worked
when i worked in support i
dot net was called dna and lightning
like the bcl like the base class
libraries versus the the runtime were
called dna and lightning and strike was
was just so we could sort of like run
this rudimentary debugging on
on.net so it's a little history lesson
that ages me a lot
i think
but what this does this e-heap dash gc
that i ran um it lists out
all of the
heaps in in.net so
all the different segments that the
garbage collector allocates i'll talk a
little bit about how that works later
but for now
um we want to look at this so this is
the 808 megabytes that we've committed
for net so we can clearly see that it is
a net problem even if we didn't have gc
dump and all that
or counters and we can run dumpheep
um
stat
and this will give the statistics that
is very very similar to what we saw in
visual studio
and lowest here is
is the one that's using up the most
memory we can see that
um
we in fact have
um 40 000
uh products
and in this case only the link size
sizes are shown
um
and
the way i would look at something like
this is i would go from the bottom and i
would go like okay so characters or
character arrays are very nondescript i
don't know
what they belong to strings okay but i
see this product that's something i can
work with and something i can kind of
like reason about whether or not that's
a reasonable number of these
and then i would go in and i would
take this first column
and i would run dumpheep
mt so the first column is called a
method table that's a descriptor for how
this object looks what methods you can
call on it what the class is and so on
and this dumps out all the
objects of that type
so these are the addresses of all the
objects i can go in then
and pick out one of the addresses i
don't know why
let's see if that worked
yeah
okay
this is not
it's very hard if i'm gonna have to um
i'm going to have to actually write
the the address of that so let's see if
we can
get this
working one more time
don't keep start we're getting the
objects
and then
copying out the product
okay good
now i can run another command that's
called dump obj or
if you want you can just run do for for
short and what this will do is it will
dump out the actual product object so as
you would see it in visual studio if you
were stopped so
we can see things like if we continue to
dump out like the name for example we
can see the name is
product 9992
so this was some string that i had
filled in and like when i created them
in the loop i named them product in in
the
index
so here we can do a little bit more
reasoning about like okay so i can if i
dump out a few of these and i see that
they all of the ones that i have have
these properties maybe that will give me
some clues
on why i'm holding on to them
and then i can also do
um gc root on this
sorry
and gc root will then do
exactly what um the gc dump thing did
where it will show me the roots of
what's going on so
in this case it tells me that that
string i was doing gc root on is a
member variable of product
this part of a list
in fact array is the
internal implementation of a list and
that is held onto by thread 790.
so if i move to threads
and i see 79d happens to be the one
we're on
marked by a star
and if i do clr stacks i see the stack
here i can see that
this is the main
um the main function of the class it's
sitting in a read line and this is sort
of like the thread that's still holding
on to the
list so basically this is just
um a quick how you would go through
these kind of
memory issues
so
um we looked at
dotnetcounters.netdump.net gc dump
and if you want to go through this and
try it out for yourself i do have them
this and everything else i'm going to go
through on my blog
and
specifically this walkthrough is
available like that's the last um one i
last post i i have in there
with all the different commands and
the video and
all of these things so don't worry about
having to
to actually remember all of these things
but i also have a set of labs on there
so the set of labs um is something like
you can download
a very bad application and you can try
to troubleshoot these things by yourself
with different prompts
okay
so why would we keep memory hanging
around well
[Music]
the only thing that keeps memory hanging
around as if if the object is not
getting ready to where it's not being
ready to be garbage collected
yet
and the things that could keep memory
around are threads so it's still being
used on the thread on the stack what not
if you have a static object
if you have cache which is like a
subset of static objects
if you pin it or span it
um or if it's
locked by the finalizer queue so we're
going to look at
a situation where the finalizer cube
blocks it oh thank you
um
in a second
but before we go into that let's talk a
little bit about memory management in
in.net
so
i mentioned and we saw in the heap gc
that we have something called segment
so as opposed to for example c plus plus
we don't allocate the memory ourself we
use a garbage collector
and a garbage collector whether it's
c-sharp or whether it's python or java
or javascript they all essentially work
a little bit the same way so what i'm
showing here is going to be roughly
equal on all of them
with a few implementation details
um
but you can think of it as
instead of you allocating them if you go
to a restaurant if they allocate like a
super big table and you just get seated
at the table so
you come into the restaurant and you get
seated the more you allocate objects the
more
the more you start filling up the table
and then you get to a point
where you reach a limit um and the limit
is i'll talk a little bit about
generations and things like that but one
limit for example is when you reach the
end of a segment
and at that point you need to garbage
collect so what you do is you go through
and you ask
anyone ready um okay so these guys are
done eating
we can then mark them as done
sweep things and compact
um the memory so
we then have more space on this segment
we continue allocating more memory
eventually we'll get to a point where we
can't actually allocate any more memory
on this segment so we'll start creating
more and more segments like this
and that's simply how
memory management works in
in a garbage collected world so marx
sweep and compactor are these phases
we do have those something called
generations and the generations are
what we what we use sort of to optimize
how the garbage collector works
so generation zero are things that are
very current
so these might be
things that you're using in your current
function
or things that
you just recently used
anything that fits
um into l2 cache so as soon as you reach
the limit which is your cpu cache we
start
collecting
the first generation
um
so
the reason why
why this is an optimization is because
anything that you allocated recently is
probably something that you will use
very close to now
where something that you've used or that
you allocated a long time ago something
that's in cash or something and that's
a little bit more long-term storage you
probably don't use as often so it
doesn't matter if you have to sort of
like swap things in and out of the cpu
but if for some reason it survives this
so if if you go through and you're not
done when it's doing collection you turn
it into generation one so you put it in
a little bit more in long term storage
than your
your current work and then eventually
when you allocate
enough for the generation one uh to be
filled
then it will move into generation two
which is your
um like that's the last generation that
exists so
generation two collections are very
expensive
compared to generation zero collections
generation zero collections happen like
this they happen very often
and generation two collections happen
very more so
much more seldom but when they do happen
they cost more
um
so
let's have a look at how
how this looks
inside um the memory dump
so
let's go ahead and open this up again
and we'll look at e heap dash gc
and we'll see these are the segments
that we have
uh right here so we have
a set of segments uh if we look at one
of them for example like this one
so we'll do dumpheep
from here to
wherever it was
what did i do
here
to where it was allocated we'll see that
this is in fact how this looks as in
it
they're allocated like one after another
all of these objects
and
if we were to dump them out we could but
um
what we
what we can see from this is that
objects on on the.net heap are immutable
in the state you cannot grow an object
you cannot grow a string for example you
would have to create a new string
because if you did grow a string
there wouldn't be space for it
because there's something
tacked on right after it right
so that means that
as we'll see in a bit if you do happen
to do something where you think you're
gonna
just expand something but you don't
that's gonna lead to trouble
but let's go ahead and
[Music]
and
have a look at another memory leak by
the way if you're interested in the
details of how memory management works
and everything
maoni who's the
architect of the gc
she's got this and a number of other
documents that's
very good explanations both of how
memory management work and what you can
do to
to make sure that your
applications are more performant
so
let's go and have a look at another um
issue with high memory usage
in this case i'm i'm not going to
capture the dump like i could capture
the dump either
through
through using gc dump or i could go in
on any process
and say create a dump file this is also
a valid way to create a memory dump of
like any it doesn't have to be your
process
as long as you're
either running it or you have privileges
higher than the person who's running it
on your system
um
and there's also a number of different
tools that you can use to create these
memory dumps
but i've already created one
and i'm going to load it up here so this
is a tool called windybg
and wendyg is
is a native debugger so
that means that
um it doesn't only understand
uh it doesn't only understand.net memory
but it also understands
other things like windows calls and the
drivers and everything that's underneath
it it's not kernel so it doesn't
actually go in the drivers is still a
user mode dump which means it's only the
process itself but it understands like
the underlying
thing is like if we if we look at the
thread
you'll see that it's like empty dll
and the starts of
or things like that so
we're going to run through
the exact same scenario here though
we're going to do
an e-version
and in this case we're going to see that
we're actually running in server mode
this is from a website
so server mode with ateps
will run e-heap
and gc
find out that we're using
200 megs of of memory so that's what
we're kind of dealing with and what we
want to dissect
and then we'll do dump stat to
understand
what the objects are that
we're loading up
if you're a little bit attached even if
you can see
what i'm writing on the screen
like you'll see that there's an
exclamation mark in here that wasn't
there in the
dot net dump case this is because in
this case i'm running sos as
a
a dollar module that windows
windowpg uses
so
whereas the commands are built in to
gcdump
but in here we can see
if we look from the bottom um a similar
scenario where we have
you know some characters array strings
string builders what not and then
eventually we run up here and we see
um some of my own things
um a link
and we have 8 000 of them
and i then go in and say okay so that
seems a little bit fishy i go in in this
case
i can run all the same commands like
dump empty and everything or i can also
click on the links here it's using
something called the bugger markup
language
that is
when you click it's actually running a
dump object or a dump in this case
so i'm listing out all the
all these links
and i go through the exact same scenario
i go open
one up for example
which is dump obj
and i click on this which does another
dump obj
and we can see that in this case it's
called like nico's weblog with some text
that was in this link
but i want to know
why this is
being kept alive
so i do gc root
and when i go through and do gc root
there's a long
list of likes i'll pick another one
maybe that's
an easier one
i'll see that it's locked by or is used
by something called a finalizer queue
so the finalizer queue
is one of the garbage collector threads
we looked here
that is specifically dedicated to only
calling your destructor so if you have a
destructor on your object if you're
trying to release some kind of native
memory or handles or whatever you might
have you might have a destructor and
this thread is the only one who's
allowed to run the structures
what that means is that if you have an
object
that uses a destructor whether or not
it's empty
it will in fact cause your your object
to at least survive generation zero
because it has to do
survive it mark it for a deletion
finalize it
and then garbage collect it
and in this case
the reason why it's sticking around or
why
um
why we're seeing this memory leak is
because
if we were to if we look at the
finalizer and this is something like
whenever you see something that's
rooted in the finalize queue
you would go in and look at the thread
and run clr stack
and in this case
it's sitting in a sleep
now obviously this is a
is something that i'm doing kind of like
to to cause the problem but you can
imagine it would be stuck for example
and do like trying to release a handle
something that's taking a lot of time
even if it just takes a little bit of
time if you release a lot of them then
it would take a lot of time to to
release all of them
okay
so um
that is an example of a memory leak
um
on the finalizer
eq so
this is
a and this is just
if you have one of these um empty
destructors you will run into
two situations and when you survive too
many times
so we used a windowpg internally this
uses.net sos and.net symbols
and you can also install these with
with.net tools
so one thing
we haven't talked about yet when it
comes to the garbage collector is is the
elephant in the room which is a large
objective
so
the large objective is a special heap um
sort of like a special
set of segments that are meant for very
large objects so any objects that are
over 85 000 bytes
for example
um
lists that are very large or or strings
that are very large etc and this is
another optimization of the garbage
collector where
because we don't want to constantly move
a list of
of 85 85 000 objects because that would
mean that we would have to move a lot of
things
we're putting them on a separate table
and
um we're garbage collecting them as
normal but
when we do garbage collect the larger
tip we don't only garbage collect a
large objective we do a full generation
two collection
so that means that if you're doing a lot
of
allocations on the large object heap
you will eventually end up exhausting
the segment making them
a large or a garbage collection of the
large habitable which then induces a
generation two
collection which is fairly expensive so
if you keep doing this you'll end up in
a very bad pattern that's causing a lot
of
bad cpu usage
which takes us to
bad performance
so bad performance
um
when we troubleshoot the problem with
bad performance
we're looking at
why is it taking so long and what are we
doing these are really the only two
questions we we should concern ourselves
with when it comes to
to bad performance problems
so let's go ahead and
and have a look at how we can
troubleshoot something like this
so in this case i have a website running
in azure
um
and
it's showing like high cpu usage from
time to time very bad response times
what not
and
what i can do in here i can go in and
click
on this
which is available on all
most services in in.net actually or
sorry in usher
and which is diagnose and solve the
problem and this has a number of
different things it allows you to do
tracing or
or logging or a lot of
things including
these diagnostic tools
that
allow you to pick
memory dumps
so
this is a way that you can create or
collect memory dumps in
in azure the back end of this tool or
what's what's behind this tool is
something called debug diag so
debug diag is a tool that you can also
run
locally on your machine and you can
equally use that to to collect for
example memory dumps when
one cpu is very high or when something
is crashing or under
various different conditions and then
it's also an analysis tool so this is
something we created in in support
where we got very tired of
troubleshooting the same kind of
problems over and over and over and over
again so we created these scripts that
would sort of like check through the
most common things
and then
generate a report for you
telling you what um what the problem
probably was
so if you go in to collect and analyze
data this is what's running in the
background
so i have a memory dump
from this
that i took before
and
i'll open it up and start the analysis
so now it's going through
if i were to run for example the memory
analysis it would then go through and
run dumpheep stat gc root like all of
these things and it will tell me
you know you're like categorize the
objects by
color by type a little bit and
give you some
heuristics about what it what it thinks
and then it would uh
show you one of these reports and the
analysis summary
now
the the fact that this is running like
mhtml and
it's like more ie like kind of tells you
how old this is but it's still something
that's very functional like even
last month i could run this and actually
come up with what
what what was what the problem was in in
one of the trouble one of the things we
were
troubleshooting so
this here tells us for example that
we
we are running the garbage collector
when the when the memory dump is taken
it also gives you some links and these
are links to my blog
for the different labs and different
troubleshooting examples
and um it also tells us in here that
um
it's working on um
it's working on
concatenating strings
but
let's go ahead and
let's just click on the link and see the
stack so this would be
the equivalent of running clr stack
so we can see here that our products
controller
is calling concat
and this is a very well known very bad
pattern
in.net so what this is doing is
for bring up
let's bring up notepad
so if you imagine you have a string
hello
and then you wanted to run you wanted to
only add
you wanted to add world but you added
one character at a time
then the first
string that you would create would look
like this and then
when you added on the o you would have
to create a new string
because of how the objects are sort of
like stacked one after another
strings are immutable so they can't grow
and this this causes you to then
allocate a lot more now what's happening
here
is that
we see a lot of cpu and garbage
collection because
if we go to the products controller in
here
and we look at the index
we'll see that
what it's actually doing is it's
bringing down all the products
and then it creates
like this html
table of all the products and this gets
very big like so where are you tacking
on one row at a time
but we're now creating
something like you know a thousand
strings
that end up being over 85 000 bytes so
what are we doing
we're exhausting the large object heap
and we're starting to generate a lot a
lot a lot of generation
two collections
and this will cause very high cpu usage
so
this is
um
a pattern that you should avoid if
you're creating very large strings it
doesn't really matter if you're just
doing sort of like
small strings and you're concatenating
three three strings then by all means
use use like the plus signs and
concatenate them together but if you're
doing something like this where you're
maybe generating a json or you're
generating some kind of
output then use a string builder instead
because the string builder
can will allocate an
array pre-allocate an array and then
once that array is full it will create
an array of double the size
so
while
in
in some cases it will create a lot
bigger array than it needs
it will definitely not create a lot of
different arrays because it will grow
sort of by double all the time and it
will maybe something like this would be
generating
i don't know maybe five allocations
versus the 10 000 allocations that the
concatenation generates
okay so
that is troubleshooting um
a high cpu usage
problem um
let's go ahead and
look at another problem which is
a low cpu usage problem so in high cpu
usage problem the process is actually
doing something and
it's constantly showing so
when you have a high cpus problem it's
normally the gc
a runaway loop
or regular expressions
like those are usually the
things that will generate like you know
these hundred percent cpu
type situations with low cpu problems
instead what you have is a process
that's actually waiting for something
else
maybe it's waiting for a database maybe
it's waiting for an api
just some other process but
this process is actually not working
much it's just
you know using up threads
so
again i captured a memory dump from
from process and in this case i'm going
to use another tool that most of you
know
visual studio to debug this memory dump
so
i'm going to open up
the memory dump um in here so
let's see
and what we have here is we have an a
little bit of information about the
memory dump like again it's using.net
six
it's running on windows 11 this is
windows 10 but it's actually windows 11.
um
and you can choose to either
debug with managed native or mixed
in this case we're going to use debug
with
managed
which is only the net part we don't care
about like the
the native parts on the stacks
and you end up in in this situation
because we don't this is a server so
this will show the active thread which
is
usually um thread zero when you when you
capture a dump unless you're in a crash
or something in which case it will show
you the active thread
but we have a lot of other
threads that are executing requests
because this is a web server so what
we're going to do is we can go in and
use
parallel stacks
and parallel stacks is not something
that's only used with memory dumps it's
something that you can very much also
use
in visual studio when you debug things
to see what the other threads are
working on
the ones that
that you're not necessarily debugging
right now and it has this neat feature
of
taking all the threads and kind of like
extracting the common parts of what the
threads are working on
so what we're seeing here is that we
have
our main which was on on the first
thread but we then have a number of
of threads 11 of them
all sitting in this products controller
feature function
and going into some
data layer um
and calling some function there
and then out of these ten
nine actually one of them is waiting for
a thread to to be free so we have 11
requests but one of them need like we
only have to we can only have 10
concurrent
with the settings so it's waiting for
for the others to be released but out of
these threads that we're actually
working uh one of nine of them are
waiting on a lock
and one of them are in is in a lock
and because i've grabbed this on the
same machine where i was or where i have
the code
or you also this also works if you have
symbols
and you have the code lined up exactly
is the code that's running on the on the
server you can go in and click
and it will take you
i'm sorry
it then activates what thread you're on
and
let's see i'll do this one more time
here and it pulls you
exactly where
where this particular thread is sitting
so in this case we we can go in and we
can see that the actual issue and what
these threats are working on is actually
you know sitting in in this case in a
sleep simulating a long-running request
while holding a lock and that's why the
other
the other threats are
are waiting
so
i find this very useful if you have the
code and everything and even if you
don't have the code just looking at the
parallel stacks is quite nice view
especially if you're not
super into
debugging with windows g this is at
least you know looking at it from a
familiar place where you're normally at
okay
so that was
reviewing a
low cpu issue and all of the dumps that
we've taken so far you could have also
done this same thing with
so we used debug diag in the background
which is azure diagnostics but you can
download and use the debug diag
um locally and visual studio from memory
dump debugging so the last thing we're
going to have a look at super super
quick is crashes and exceptions
so if we have
a process that crashed the only thing
we're really concerned with is what the
heck just happened like so what would
cause the crash
and i'm going to use
the same
use visual studio in this case also to
debug it now one thing i do want to
mention when you capture a dump of a
memory leak or if a process or of a
performance issue you can just go in and
the task manager you can run gc dump and
all of these things because you take a
snapshot of the process right now when
it's happening
for something like a crash
it's not possible to catch it in the act
like you would have to be super super
fast and very very accurate with your
timing to catch it in the act so instead
we have to run something like debug diag
and set it up so that it will catch a
memory dump when it crashes
or proc dump
from system internal instances internals
is also or windows error reporting so
windows error reporting you can set up
also to to capture dumps of any process
that crashes and it will it will then
collect the dumps from you for you that
you can
troubleshoot like this
so let's have a look at
how that looks
and
i'm going to stop this
and i'm going to do the same thing debug
with managed
i'll go ahead and kill these parallel
stacks because now because it was a
crash dump it took me to the very place
where it was crashing so this was a null
reference exception
um because this is a native dump it
shows it as an access violation but you
can see here that just like as if you
were debugging something live you can
see the code you can see things like
the objects
and their values so you can hover over
them the only thing you can't do is you
can't move forward because this is still
a snapshot so you can't like it's not a
live debugging session you can't uh
you can't kind of carry on from here but
but at least it gives you a very good
tool and a very
in my book at least a comfortable tool
to work with for troubleshooting these
things
and again the reason why you would use a
dump here is because
maybe it doesn't happen when you try to
step by step debug or maybe it happens
on someone else's machine
and that
kind of concludes um
this but
i hope you got enough out of this um in
terms of tools and techniques to go and
troubleshoot them on your own but less i
said
if you're looking to try them out before
you have your own problem or if you're
looking to sort of get references on on
how to do these
these labs are
are pretty okay for that i think
so thank you so much
and i hope you have a great
day moving on